most impacted States New Yorkers at
83,000 New Jersey is at 18,000 that's
Governor Phil Murphy who's been a great
partner to me great partner to the
people of this state governor Ned Lamont
also in Connecticut has been a great
partner we've done a lot of great work
as a region which is very unusual you
know those lines between states often
become walls not with governor Murphy
and not with governor Lamont we're
working together and we're gonna work
cooperatively with New Jersey because
they have a real problem
California's ticking up Michigan's
taking up Florida is even taking up
Massachusetts but no is no one has
anywhere near where we are right
eighty-three thousand compared to 18
number of deaths 1900 up from 1550 that
number will continue to go up that is
people who have been on ventilators for
a period of time if you go on a
ventilator there's roughly only a 20%
chance that you will come off the
ventilator the longer you're on the
ventilator the lower the chance you come
off we're still looking for a curve
we're still looking to see where we hit
the plateau total number of new
hospitalized again you see the number
goes up and down but the overall
trajectory of the number is up changing
ICU admissions bouncier bounced there
but the overall number is still up
change in intubations same thing the
line is basically a line that is going
up change in number of discharged line
is going up why more people going in
more people treated more people coming
out everyone asks the same questions and
they're all good questions when is this
going to be over what happens how does
it end
and people want answers I understand
people want answers I want answers but
the can sir is nobody knows for sure
anyone who goes on cable TV and says or
network TV and says this is what is
going to happen that's not it's not true
nobody knows what's going to happen and
I understand the need for closure the
need for control we're at a place we've
never been before or we're out of
control I need to know I need to know
nobody can tell you what you do know are
facts and you know facts of funny things
what you're now getting are subjective
facts people who are optimists want to
interpret it one way people who are
pessimists want to interpret the other
way people who bring their own
subjective agenda tend to interpret the
numbers a different way for me facts are
facts and the facts that we offer the
people of this state and the people of
this country they're not pessimistic
facts or optimistic facts they're not
interpreted facts they are just the best
information we have as of this time and
I think that is empowering and in some
ways relaxing as I mentioned through you
who've worked with me I say to my team
all the time I don't I'm interested in
your opinion but I'm interested in your
opinion second I'm interested in the
facts first and give me the facts
unjaded by your opinion because once a
person has an opinion or once a person
wants a certain outcome and they look at
the facts through that filter then you
can interpret facts differently just
give me the straight facts sergeant Joe
Friday just the facts ma'am just effects
no opinion there's something empowering
to that
we look for the facts - projection
models that's how we gauge what we do we
follow the projection model every day
you get additional data they run that
data into the model and they refine the
model and basically we then have a
composite model because you have many
different people out there with many
different models we use McKinsey which
is a consultant to the state for this
purpose to basically look at all the
models and come up with a composite
model and if people wonder well where do
you get these numbers governor where do
you how do you decide what you're going
to do we have a model we have a
projection and that's what we follow the
current model and the model by the way
even more maddening the model changes
the more data that comes in because they
started with assumptions and
presumptions and then the more data that
comes in either affirms or discounts
their presumptions that they started
with so they refine the model over time
and the model changes and the numbers
change but what we're looking at now is
the apex top of the curve roughly at the
end of April which means another month
of this the apex the recent number is
you could need 110 hung 110,000 kovat
beds what does that mean beds for kovat
people as opposed to other people who
are in the hospitals for other reasons
37,000 ventilators that is our current
model that model that model is based on
minimum or minimal impact from social
distancing meaning what one of the great
variables
is how effective is the social distance
are people doing it are they complying
with it and to what extent and how
effective is it nobody knows that answer
so they do different projections
depending on how well social distancing
works how well people comply with it and
then how effective it is minimal social
distancing impact is where we get the
110,000 37,000 I see ventilators high
compliance with social distancing you
still have 75,000 corporate beds as
opposed to 110 your twenty five thousand
ventilators okay so when I keep pushing
for high compliance on social distancing
it's because high compliance on social
distancing will reduce the number this
is where they began talking about
flatten the curve flat and curved
flatten the curve with social distancing
this says this is the difference between
high compliance with social distancing
and less compliance if you have high
compliance you're down to 75,000 covered
beds 25,000 ventilators less it goes up
to 110 and 37 interestingly both are
looking at the same point of apex it's
just a lower apex both models say you
apex at the end of April just lower a
lower need at that apex and that is what
we want because this all comes down to
at the apex can your hospital system
manage the volume of people coming into
the hospital system that's all this is
about at the final analysis now there
are also different models out there
based on different presumptions people
study China people studied Wuhan well if
you have the same compliance that you
hadn't moved on
Wuhan base
just locked up society I don't even know
that if the federal government enacted
the Wuhan model that the American people
would comply we have a totally different
social structure governmental structure
so you have different models that
project higher or lower what we're doing
with Mackenzie is studying all of them
and coming up with a moderate model that
is a basis for us to make planning
decisions because I have to make
decisions and I want to make the
decisions off the numbers so that's what
we're doing it's not to say that there
aren't other people with other opinions
there are many people with many opinions
and some have the apex tuning star apex
happening sooner some have the apex
happening later you can find people who
believe the apex will come in seven days
you can have people who say the apex
won't come for six weeks you have that
kind of range you have a broad range on
the number of beds you have a broad
range on the number of ventilate
ventilators our course for planning
purposes is a moderate model because in
truth the higher models we don't even
have a chance meeting that capacity
anyway you say over a hundred and ten
thousand beds there is no possible way
we could get there so in some ways an
overly aggressive estimate doesn't even
mean anything to us because it's just
unachievable people ask well what's
going to happen and doctor foul Qi said
yesterday or the day before the day's
blend together estimated 100,000
Americans may pass away some people have
said 100 to 200 thousand Americans may
pass away before this is over when is it
over when you achieve what
called herd immunity how do you say 100
to 200 that's a broad range well it goes
back to the other point nobody really
knows but 100 to 200 you're saying a
significant amount of people lose their
lives there is a group that is funded by
the Gates Foundation
thank you very much Bill Gates that
projects 93 thousand Americans will lose
their life by the time this is over that
model suggests 16,000 New Yorkers will
pass away by the time this is runs its
course
my guess is so when when dr. Fauci says
100 thousand there are models out there
that make these types of projections and
what would that mean to New York that
would mean about 16,000 frankly that
would mean that New York is only 16
percent roughly of the number of deaths
I don't even understand that since New
York is so much higher right now but
what that does say to the rest of the
nation is this is not just New York if
you believe these numbers 16,000 deaths
in New York that means you're going to
have tens of thousands of deaths outside
of New York so to the extent people
watch their nightly news in Kansas and
say well this is a New York problem
that's not what these numbers say it
says it's a New York problem today
tomorrow
it's a Kansas problem in a Texas problem
and a New Mexico problem that's why I
say to my fellow governors and elected
officials all across this country look
at us today see yourself tomorrow and
let's address it in New York and let's
cooperate to address it in New York
because it's going to be in your town
tomorrow metaphorically and if we learn
how to do it right here or learn how to
do it the best we can because there is
no right it's only the best we can then
we can work cooperatively all across
this country the other thing this model
says people say well when is it over two
weeks three weeks four weeks this model
projects you're going to have a high
death rate through July if this model is
correct this could go through the summer
now other people talk about getting back
to work starting the economy April May
June this model says it could go on
through July now the questions become
nuanced well could you still be dealing
with the virus and get the economy up
and running and get people out of their
homes yes I think there are ways to do
both not not picking between human life
and the dollar bill because no one is
going to pick a dollar bill over human
life but can you come up with a public
health strategy that is consistent with
people getting out of their homes and
starting to get back to work yes you can
my opinion is the best way to do that is
to come up with a rapid testing
procedure where people can test they
know who's positive they know who's
negative and they know who can go back
to work and come up with a test quickly
and they're starting that is readily
available that people can do at home so
you can take the test know where you are
and we can start ending this this
terrible situation that we're in also
you come up with testing and rapid
testing not only do you get up and get
the economy running you end the anxiety
the anxiety is what is most oppressive
here not knowing not knowing if I'm
positive if my friend is positive if my
loved one is positive not knowing when
this is going to end the anxiety of
dealing with this isolation day after
day after day is like a bad groundhog
movie you know day after day after day
when does it end how does it end I don't
know I'm out of control
I think the testing is going to be the
best mechanism to try to work through
that on the good news front we have new
testing available in New York Regeneron
which is a great New York company has
created 500,000 testing kits at no
charge Thank You Regeneron
and they are distributing them across
the state Corning another great company
has donated 100,000 tubes and $500,000
at reduced cost so we can do more tests
New York is very aggressive on testing
we have been from day one and we think
that has helped us slow the spread of
this virus
my favorite topic young people must get
this message and they still have not
gotten the message you still see too
many situations with too much density by
young people they can get it that
putting their lives at risk this can
kill young people rare circumstances but
it can but you get infected you give it
to someone else so think about somebody
else and I've said this 100 different
ways the compliance is still not where
it should be
you sword the mob you saw the models on
the differential in the compliance
versus major compliance and minor
compliance so we're going to take more
dramatic actions we're going we are
going to close down the New York City
playgrounds I've talked about this for
weeks
I warned people that if they didn't stop
the density and the games in the
playgrounds you can't play basketball
you can't come in contact with each
other
that we would close the playgrounds I've
spoken to speaker Johnson from New York
City who feels very strongly about this
who did from day one we agreed initially
with the mayor that we would try
compliance and the mayor was going to
try to use the NYPD to enforce
compliance social distancing in
playgrounds it is still a problem we're
working with the speaker we're working
with the mayor but we're going to close
down the city playgrounds and leave the
open spaces available so use the open
space in a park walk around get some Sun
great no density no basketball games no
close contact no violation of social
distancing period that's the rule other
good news we are working with all the
hospitals in the state to do something
they have never done before which is to
act as one to cooperate to share
supplies share staff support one another
shift patients among hospitals which
really has never happened to any great
extent and the hospitals have been very
cooperative and I want to thank them
very much in this war we must plan
forward for the next battle meaning we
have been behind from day one this virus
has been ahead of us from day one you
don't win a war that way the next battle
is the apex the next battle is on the
top of the mountain you see that curve
you see a curve I see a mountain the
next battle will happen
at the top of that mountain that's where
it is going to be joined and that's
where the enemy either overwhelms our
healthcare system or we are able to
handle beyond slot of the enemy at the
top of that mountain and that's what
we're planning for every day but I'm
going to offer you a different
perspective that I'm starting to think
about and I think we all should start to
think about as a society beyond just
this immediate situation we should start
looking forward to understand how this
experience is going to change us or how
it should change us because this is
going to be transformative it is going
to be transformative on a personal basis
on a social basis on a systems basis
we're never going to be the same again
we're not going to forget what happened
here
the fear that we have the anxiety that
we have that's not just going to go away
when do we get back to normal I don't
think we get back to normal I think we
get back or we we get to a no normal
right like we're seeing in so many
facets of society right now so we will
be at a different place our challenge is
to make sure that transformation and
that change is positive and not negative
let's make sure we're taking the
positive lesson and not the negative
lesson you could get weary of intimacy
and contact and density social
distancing don't go near anyone what a
terrible thing to live with as a human
being what a cruel torture isolate
yourself from other people be afraid
of hugging someone just think how
emotionally and personally repugnant
that concept is right we crave human
connection and now we're being told that
could be dangerous you can't kiss you
can't hug you can't hold hands so how
how we come out of this and making sure
that it's positive and not negative how
do we learn from this and how do we grow
from this right society life you will
get knocked on your rear end you will
deal with pain you will deal with death
you will deal with setback you would
deal with suffering question is how do
you get up but first do you get up and
second if you get up how do you get up
do you get up smarter do you get up
wiser or do you get up bitter and you
get up angry and do you better get up
fearful we are in control of that and we
have to start to think about that and we
also have to be smarter from what we
went through how do you make the economy
more resilient what happens when
something like this happens again and
something like this will happen again oh
no this is a once-in-a-lifetime never
again something like this will happen
again we're seeing it in the environment
we're seeing with floods we're seeing
with hurricanes something like this will
happen again you can't just turn off the
economy like the light switch
how do governments work together you
can't figure it out on the fly what the
federal government does what the state
government does what the local
governments do figure it out before
learn the lessons from this telemedicine
and and tella education we have to close
the schools well why weren't we ready
with a tella education system why
weren't we better at
telemedicine why didn't we have that
capacity rather than having people wait
on all these lines that come in to get
the same basic diagnosis and the same
basic advice why don't we have medical
supplies made in this country why are we
shopping in China for basic medical
supplies
why don't we here our medical research
to these types of threats and challenges
which we know are on the horizon we know
these viruses are changing we know that
they mutate why don't we get ahead of it
you still have to run society let's talk
about first responder capacity we now
have first responders who are getting
sick and the workforce is dropping well
that was inevitable right that was going
to happen
what's the backup to that situation and
let's talk about societal stability and
engagement at times of crisis you can't
just tell everyone go home and lock your
doors and sit on your couch and order
takeout for the foreseeable future
that's not who we are it's not even a
mental health issue it's just it's our a
personal health issue it's how we how
how we relate to one another we're not
built to be isolated for long periods of
time and not have human contact so how
do we deal with that and these are the
types of questions that we have to start
to think through but not today that is
the next challenge I believe and that is
what we're going to have to think about
soon but for now one crisis at a time
as they say and we are planning to
handle with the current crisis preparing
for the battle on the Mount
which is what we are doing every day and
that's what we are doing
and not only are we doing it but we have
to succeed at it you know government
process is very good at saying well
we're trying we're working on this we're
doing our best we're doing our best
Winston Churchill it is knows no you
saying we are doing our best you have
got to succeed in doing what is
necessary tad harsh goes with that
expression which I think you could say
tad harsh handsome but a tad harsh but
it's true and that's what I say my team
to my team every day
this is beyond best efforts this is
beyond I'm working very hard we have to
get this done we have to succeed we have
to find a way we have to make it happen
because too much is at stake last point
on a personal note my brother
Christopher as I told you yesterday
tested positive for the corona virus
he's at home he's doing fine enough he
has a fever he has chills symptoms of
basically a very bad flu but I want I
think this is illustrate a luster dove
in a number of ways first of all anyone
can get this disease relatively young
people strong people people who take a
lot of vitamin pills people who go to
the gym a lot anyone can get this
disease there is no superhero who is
immune from this disease that goes for
New Yorker as well as a Texan as the law
as well as a California anyone can get
it no one can be protected from it I
couldn't protect my own brother
with all he knows and as smart as he is
he couldn't protect himself so anyone
can get it and everyone has to be
protected I understand the data
I understand 80% self resolved 20% Phil
in the hospital's Christopher is not in
the category that is problematic by all
the data he should have it he'll have it
for a period of time and he will then
resolve if he has bad symptoms have gone
to the hospital he'll be treated and
he'll be released that's what all the
numbers said even though that's what all
the numbers say when he told me he had
the coronavirus it scared me
it frightened me why because we still
don't know we still don't know and even
if there's just a 1% 2% chance it's
frightening it is frightening frightened
me and I deal with all sorts of stuff
and I've seen all sorts of things and it
frightened me why because we're talking
about my brother talking about my little
brother this is my best friend talked to
him several times a day basically spent
my whole life with him and it is
frightening on a fundamental level and
it's frightening because there's nothing
I can do and I'm out of control and
there's nobody who can tell me and dr.
Zucker can't tell me anything
and Tony Falchi can't tell me anything
because nobody really knows and this
situation is the same situation for
everyone for everyone
so yes I'm frightened for my brother I'm
worried about my brother
as everyone is worried about everyone in
their family and everybody they love I
take solace in the numbers and the facts
because you can't divorce yourself from
the facts otherwise you go to a place of
irrationality but we're emotional beings
and as an emotional beam it is
frightening and it is unknown and it is
threatening and it is scary and people
are dying he's gonna be okay I believe
that he's in his basement and I sent him
over a book that could be helpful
beginner's guide to striped bass fishing
I hope he picks up some tips from that
but I also want to say to him because I
want him to know he found out yesterday
morning that he had coronavirus he did
his show last night he did a show last
night from his basement what a gutsy
courageous thing to do and we talked
about it and in some ways this can be
very instructive I think to many people
because everybody wants to know well
what happens if you get coronavirus all
right he did and he does this show every
night maybe some nights he won't be able
to do it but he does his show every
night so what's the positive show the
country what it means to have
coronavirus and that information that
experience can be helpful to people and
that's why he did the show last night
okay I have coronavirus but you know
what Here I am I'm doing my show I
didn't fall over
I didn't collapse it's not a death
sentence Here I am I'm doing my show
kudos to him my pop would be proud I
love you little brother and even though
this isn't a flattering picture
I did not pick this picture with your
mouth open but it is suitable in some
ways any questions comments you could
repeat that please because I missed it
all so let's do any questions or
coronavirus if you want to do questions
on budget or anything else let's do them
at the end but I'm sorry I didn't use
your what's the state's policy for
posthumous
corona virus testing I have no idea you
know so it this is based on a clinical
picture right so if someone died as a
result of respiratory illnesses the
person would be tested to be sure and
trying to figure out what happened to
them because there are contexts that
that person has has been exposed to so
when we here we know those who have died
and if they're tested at the time of
autopsy those are included in the deaths
you confirm that there were some
patients who were moved from New York
City to as well were their patients who
were moved coronavirus patients moved
from New York City to Albany med yes and
we've talked about this is one state
this is one family of New York this is
one family of the United States of
America by the way we support one
another in two ways staff from upstate
hospitals will be going to downstate
hospitals because one of the real
critical situations are staff shortages
and staff exhaustion so upstate staff
will come help the downstate Hospital
and downstate hospitals who are at over
capacity can transfer patients to
Upstate Kovac patients it depends on the
patient but if the if they're in a place
where the hospital can't treat them then
it's better to move them and be in a
hospital setting where they came to
treat we're doing this now does that
mean that the downstate hospitals are
full I know that the toh has data on
beds including ICU beds can you make
that available and also if you set a
hundred ten thousand beds for Kovac what
is the total capacities it's still a
hundred forty thousand about one hundred
and forty-one tantric Ovid would suggest
you have thirty thousand non-covered
patients we tried to bring down the non
we tried to bring down the patient count
by mandating no elective surgery that
was non critical so people are not going
into the hospital right now to have a
hip replacement unless they really need
it they're not going in for any type of
elective surgery so forth a number of
patients down so we could get more
covert patients in the transfer from New
York City the New York City Hospital to
Albany Medical was more of a one-off
situation which had been individually
arranged we are now Department of Health
is now coordinating all transfers and
you're right the first step is transfers
within the system so downstate New York
you have the healthy hnh system transfer
among the 11 HNH hospitals to balance
load balance capacity and transfer among
the private hospitals to balance load
then transfer among those two systems
and then worst-case scenario transfer
upstate passes left between 18h in the
private hospitals and it I guess
long island divorce Chester to
you know and they are not at capacity
now it depends on how fast that curve
goes up we monitor monitor it on a daily
basis and that's the $64,000 question
Jimmy is when you get to the apex you
will be over capacity any of those
models by the way say you are over
capacity you're over 100% by any model
at the apex it's going to be right the
transfer that happened was basically a
one-off because they were hospitals that
had a pre-existing agreement but what
will happen going forward the battle on
the mount will be capacity you fill all
the downstate hospitals and your over
capacity on all the downstate hospitals
you then have Javits Center as a relief
valve you have that ship the comfort as
a relief valve but they only take non
kovat patients you try to transfer to
Long Island as Long Island does that
capacity then you move upstate it's a
pure capacity issue pure systems
management issue
yeah look I we had this conversation
with the city it's part of the closing
the playgrounds the NYPD has to get more
aggressive period period well it's not a
law enforcement issue it is and if by
the way if you want to if you're gonna
force me into a position where I have to
mandate it and make it a law a social
distancing law that would which I think
is absurd but it has to be enforced
first how reckless and irresponsible and
selfish for people not to do it on their
own I mean what else do you have to know
what else do you have to hear who else
has to die
for you to understand you have a
responsibility in this right I mean it's
it's just really so incredible
especially in New Yorkers who live in a
dense environment and know how
interdependent they are on one another
right and this is a situation where one
person sneezes and I get infected
so our own social responsibility the
individual responsibility the civic duty
but beyond that yeah we are going to
need law enforcement to get more
aggressive sick are there any plans to
shore up the workhorses of the first
responders we will do whatever we have
to do if NYPD people are getting sick
they will get sick FDNY people
firefighters will get sick it will get
sick the backfill will
from state police and we're working on
that
state police already of total
jurisdiction within New York City second
we could deputize police officers from
upstate communities to serve in New York
City if we get to that point now the
NYPD is so large I don't know that we
get to that point but if we believe we
don't have the minimum personnel to
police New York City we could then go to
the State Police worst comes to worst we
could deputize other officers same thing
with firefighters how many volunteer
medical well first the hospitals we have
a pool of about 78,000 it's 82,000 right
now we have a pool of 82,000 people who
say they want to help
we then route them to the hospitals the
hospital's basically will employ them so
they have to fit the needs of the
hospital and the hospital has to vet
them because they're going to be in that
hospital and performing services so it's
really now at this point as quickly as
those hospitals can make those decisions
is as quickly as people of being hired
we don't have a census yet I don't know
if we have anything anecdotal we've made
the population available to the
hospitals and they know that they know
the regions the geographic locations
they know the specialties but they want
to be careful that they're actually
picking a person who's qualified to
perform the duties do we know well let
me just do you have a number there are
three hospitals that have already
contacted the portal they're looking at
about 1,500 personnel and hopefully
those connections by talking to the
hospitals will be at least hired by
Thursday when they're in the hospitals
unknown that has to be worked out
between the hospital and the healthcare
employees themselves
we're gonna let them work that through
and then we'll put some of that out
after they work out some of those
arrangements for their own privacy yes
they have we don't have numbers yet on
exactly how many we don't have the same
density issue in the playgrounds upstate
that we've had downstate if we do I
would when we need them the temporary
hospitals are the ultimate overflow
valve and not without difficulties in
and of themselves right they are really
the last of the last resort
you still need staff you still need
equipment they are really available if
you max out your bed capacity my fear is
on the hospital capacity there are three
components beds which literally mean
beds staff and equipment you will run
out of staff before you will run out of
beds and you may run out of equipment
before you run out of staff that's the
situation we're in what do you make of
religious charities like Samaritan's
Purse
anybody who can help
god bless around the federal stop pile
after we saw the story in Politico about
us CID having issues sending our
supplies other countries while we the
federal government was ostensibly
sending people to go to other countries
to look for supplies on the confusion
there the mayor Chicago has said that
she is skeptical the federal
government's being completely honest
with her about the stockpile do you
think when we speak with President Trump
and other folks at the White House
do you think they're being completely
honest and truthful with you about the
sock well I don't know what they have in
the stockpile I only know what I read
and look I was in the federal government
I don't even know is there one stockpile
are there multiple stockpiles I don't
know do I think the federal government
has enough in the collective stockpiles
enough in their possession to meet the
need I don't know but I pray that they
do because that is the only option I
cannot buy a ventilator for a million
dollars well maybe for a million dollars
I could buy a ventilator but you cannot
buy ventilators remarkably in a real
cruel twist of fate China is the main
manufacturer for all these things it all
comes back to China where do we get the
message China where do we get the gowns
China where do we get the gloves China
where do we get the ventilators China I
mean it's I don't know how we got into
this position and then China is selling
to the world literally so a state and
every governor will tell you this
they're trying to buy I'm trying to buy
I'm calling everyone I know but it all
comes back to China and then you have
the federal government that is also
buying so really the only hope for a
state at this point is the federal
government's capacity to deliver that's
why the defense production Act came up
weeks ago right the defense production
Act gives the President of the United
States power to say to a company you
make this though the discussion was
about ventilators
look you have a shortfall on gowns
American companies can make gowns
they're not like wedding gowns they're
like paper gowns make the gowns make the
gloves make the masks you know why are
we running out of these basic supplies
we need to maybe rethink some systems
does this made you to make you more of
an advocate for something like either a
universal basic income or maybe a
single-payer centrally managed health
system which is kind of what you're
doing now I don't know Jimmy
the it I think it's even more basic than
that how do you keep the economy running
see no system will work if the entire
economy is closed down universal basic
income who's supposed to pay you know if
nothing is working
yeah they're just printing money but you
know there's only so long you can print
money you can keep the printing press
running but ultimately there has to be
some revenue being generated somewhere
how do you have a resilient economy how
do people really work from home
you
you
Society
you
tell everyone
you
take
you